Hello people in line for prayers-oh here. Oh here-We go. This is the prayer line remember your (right) your prayer didn't work
Lakewood Church?
Joel Osteen Prayerlines is here, how may I pray with you?
Hello I have a prayer I-I need to get off my chest
Okay what's your prayer request?
My prayer
is
um
that I-uh-I-was I just was curious about Joel Osteen
I just wanted a prayer about-
pray for him
Is he around right now?
This is the prayer line
It's the prayl-pra-like pralines?
No this is the prayer line
Oh, okay, so...
You asking me if he around
Yeah explain to me how it works-explain to me how this works, I'm new to this
How does it work
Hold the sausages. What is your name?
My name is Rick
*hilaugh*
Rick
Rick fatherGod
Rick fatherGod Jesus solo
Rick
till you get Lord Gat
in the name of Jesus
Are you talking in tongues..?
right now..?
Hold on-
Hold on- I-
How does it work the prayer-
How does it work the prayer- the pray line
I need to talk to Joel Osteen
It's a very important-
message
I have lots of money right now.
I have-
I have- I have over eighty seven thousand dollars
Ohh
And I am ready
er- ah- sorry, I have
eighty-three
eighty-three thousand
eight hundred and ninety seven dollars
right now
for Joel Osteen
and I'm ready to-
and I'm ready to- pray
Let's pray together
Down
Call back tomorrow
How- How mu-
How much do you get paid
to do-
to- to answer the pray line
Uh well you know what
They ain't no of your
Get  a whole lotta
La La
Po a
She Da Da Daaa
What?
Ahh
Sorry say that again
Let the Holy Spirit
Spirit- Let the Holy-
Spirit tell you
Did you just talk in... tongues?
Dare Da Dada
Ba Ba Sa Ka
Are you talking in some made-up- is that- is that Klingon?
You talking in Klingon?
Is that baby talk? I-I
You keep saying Ricky. Do you know someone named Ricky?
Ricky tatata tatata
What does-what does any of this mean? I'm confused.
Is it-i-if I were to translate this, would it be-uh-would it be like "Hey don't let people into the building
during the flood
because we don't want their dirty footsteps walking on our nice carpets.
I heard you the first time, yeah, I heard it the first time, "...blood of Jesus"
Uh-huh. 2015-2015 was a good year
Flight news. Flight News Battles, is that a magazine you read?
What are you talking about?
I am so confused right now. Is this supposed to be some kind of-
Yes, oh, it's a prayer line. Is that-is it a prayer line where you just ramble crazy nonsense?
What language is this? I just-I'm gonna call my translator, so I can follow the conversation.
Ricky Papa Chak Ricky totty totty Papa
Ricky Tati papi papi got tucked up up up up up Ricky. Ticky tacky Bucky Bucky tacky Tuggy
You're laughing at it, cause you know, it's funny, cause it's ridiculous. That's why you're laughing right now.
I just made you laugh at your own ridiculousness.
You are cracking up and rikki-tikki tucky. Tucky. Tucky. Buggy, buggy buggy buggy buggy
You're dying.
Oh she said
She's gonna put me up to the next level as prayerline. She's go just at all
She's
Speaking and talk I cannot believe what I just heard that was insane
Do you know what's amazing I?
Was dodging questions by talking and nonsense, baby. Talk. I can't believe that people actually just start like
To me talking with time, so it's so like it's so like
She's like it's the spirit taking her my ass
Evangelical super church's, it's so silly. Yup, and they say when it hits you when it hits you
Just let it out and it's like sort of this weird like improv session